[Music]
the remains of Germanwings flight 9525
cling to an alpine mountainside
thousands of pieces of the plane are
scattered across a remote stretch of the
French Alps
these fragments are all that's left of
an Airbus a320 carrying a hundred and
fifty people recovery teams scrambled to
the area have recovered the flights
blackbox recorder
it will provide vital information it
will explain what happened to the plane
and why her passengers never made it to
their destination
the search-and-rescue teams have been
told already that their job will be long
and difficult and they've been warned a
mission is likely to be a recovery
operation of AmeriCorps doornail
we were given precise coordinates but we
could only see some small debris at
first but from afar it is hard to
actually see the place of impact we kept
looking and we began seeing thousands of
small fragments we tried looking for
some sign of survivors but it was
impossible to see anything that could
have survived impossible
none of the passengers or crew on board
are likely to have survived a hiker who
returned from the scene reported one of
utter devastation we knew some more
distal ulna there is nothing to see
anymore
you can see practically nothing there's
debris of course there are no pieces
anymore there's nothing nothing like the
plane has totally disappeared this is
the Germanwings Airbus a320 filmed in
2014
[Applause]
on today's doomed flight there were 144
passengers and six crew members we are
in mourning I wanted to confirm that all
means necessary are being put into place
to find out the circumstances behind
this accident and recover the victims
the accident took place in a very
difficult area to access and it will
take several hours for the emergency
services to arrive on the scene I want
to thank all the emergency services and
civil protection authorities that are
deploying including the John dar Murray
the army and administrative units to get
there as quickly as possible
several ministers are enroute it set off
from Barcelona in Spain this morning at
901 GMT it was expected to reach
Dusseldorf in Germany nearly two hours
later the Airbus 320 reached 38,000 feet
before it started descending and then it
lost contact with air traffic control at
around 6,000 feet over the French Alps
less than an hour into the flight
it's thought have come down somewhere
between Dean Luba and Barcelona's me to
Neath Amadas alt math my thoughts and my
condolences those of the entire German
government are for those who lost their
lives so suddenly among them also many
compatriots the suffering of their
families right now is beyond measure we
do everything to ensure they have access
to all the support and help that is
possible at such a time the slight
yellow 4 million is gets the plane lost
altitude at an alarming speed 30,000
feet in less than 8 minutes flight
tracker radar shows it climbed steadily
over the Mediterranean after takeoff and
within half an hour it had reached
38,000 feet but almost as soon as it had
got to cruising altitude it began to
drop rapidly
French officials say no distress call
was made
there have been 6600 odds of this
aircraft type built in the 25 odd years
that airbus have been building them they
don't crash in the crews this aircraft
was cruising at at a typical cruising
rate it could have been anything in
excess of 450 knots and for it to fall
out the sky at such a rapid rate of
descent is unprecedented so I'm starting
to think well and as all analysts are
starting to think well engine failure is
one thing but then it would have
continued for some time of course these
aircraft are designed to glide some
distance as well and it's unusual that
you would get failure of both engines in
fact one engine failure it is is almost
completely rare
the tragedy is spread across Europe
hearts ache four lives lost in Spain
and here in Germany 16 children from
this high school were on their way home
to be reunited with their waiting
families
they'd been away for a week in Spain on
a language exchange program
the children were barely teenagers most
just 15 years old what is much too soon
is I would like to say at first but the
town is deeply shaken we're in a state
of shock
it's the worst thing imaginable the
relatives are being cared for by
specialists by spiritual advisors and
psychologists we are all with the
relatives and the victims with all our
thoughts first the relatives heard them
using the media and did some research
themselves and then when the plane
didn't land and they were unable to make
contact with their friends and
classmates by cell phone that's when
they assumed the worst so some of the
parents drove to düsseldorf some came to
the school heightened emotion and school
and others this is the Crisis Centre in
Dusseldorf where some of the anguished
parents came there's another one in
Berlin too so could you go in France the
emergency center was visited by
President Hollande and Spain's King
Philippe the monarch is here on an
official visit but has now cancelled his
trip to return home to deal with the
tragedy chemistry upon a few interest
that really mr. Tarrou at the end there
in the first place I'd like to say we've
heard about this awful accident that
took place this morning on French
territory in the south of the country in
the Alps a plane from Barcelona crashed
and we know that there are many victims
and we don't know whether there are
survivors amongst the victims there are
a high number of Spanish Nationals
alongside Germans and also Turks in the
first place I'd like to express on
behalf of the Queen and president Ilan
and myself my profound condolences from
the bottom of my heart to the families
who've lost loved ones
I'd like to transmit our pain to the
German and Turk
authorities for their dead and I would
like to also express to the French
authorities the French president and the
Prime Minister our gratitude for all the
measures they've immediately put in
action the operation to attend to this
catastrophe as we know is very
complicated because of the location
where it took place
yamagishi ramos does me peered out
Audrey as Francis's I present the land
I've given me he's through it's believed
some 45 passengers and board the
Germanwings plane was Spanish
arrangements are now being made to take
their relatives to France to the crash
site even though French investigators
say it could be days before the bodies
of the victims are found and retrieved
what more can I say at the moment well
all I can tell you is that obviously I'm
very sad as many are about this very
dramatic accident we are going to do
everything we can within our powers in
our hands to help anything that is
possible tell the families what to give
them our support the Airbus a320 has a
strong safety record but that will now
be under further scrutiny it's been in
operation since 1988 that's 27 years in
the sky over that time the aircraft has
carried some six billion passengers
that's around 86 percent of the world's
population it's a short to medium-range
commercial airliner meaning it doesn't
fly long-haul and there are currently
6157 of them in operation with one
taking off or landing somewhere in the
world every two seconds every day
the a320 typically carries around 150
passengers it can fit up to a 180
depending on the layout it's not only
used by Germanwings which is part of
Lufthansa but also by many airlines
including British Airways easyJet and
Air France
the a320 has a strong safety record
although there have been 11 previous
crashes that resulted in loss of life
162 people were killed
Air Asia flight 8501 crashed into the
Java Sea in Indonesia over Christmas the
cause of that is still under
investigation and the plane that was
guided into the Hudson River in New York
by its pilot when its engines failed in
2009 was also an a320 everyone at
Lufthansa and German ways it's currently
deeply shocked and saddened by these
events there's not too much of
information that I can give to you right
now but please be assured that for
Lufthansa it's of greatest importance to
now focus on the investigation of this
of this accident it's now the most
important thing to get the information
to get the information to the relatives
and friends and that is our main focus
as well to support them all wherever
they are and whichever nationality they
have the crash slides has been described
as a horror scene nothing of the plane
remains intact its fuselage ripped and
shredded all indications suggest
everyone on board has been killed
but rescue teams will stay on the
mountainside tonight to resume a
difficult painstaking task in the
morning they will do everything in their
power to answer the many many prayers
been offered across Europe Ashish Joshi
sky news